[Música]
israel y gaza vive en su primera mañana
de calma luego de 11 días de escalada
bélica tras entrar en vigor esta
madrugada una tregua de cs el cuerpo
palestinos en la franja cisjordania y
jerusalén celebraron en las calles ambos
adjudican la victoria tenemos reportes
es éste la vida
una treintena de inmigrantes logró
entrar esta madrugada a la ciudad
española de melilla la policía y la
guardia civil tratan de controlar esta
zona fronteriza con territorio marroquí
a principios de esta semana unos 8000
migrantes llegaron de manera irregular
al también enclave español de ceuta
la unión europea llegó a un acuerdo
sobre un certificado digital de coín 19
a partir del próximo primero de julio
que podrán aportar los habitantes del
bloque un pacto que evitará medidas como
cuarentenas aunque se reservan el
derecho a hacerlo si es necesario les
explicamos en qué consiste
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto acompañarlos esta mañana
comenzamos en medio oriente donde se
mantiene la calma entre israel y gaza
tras el reciente alto el fuego desde
entonces no han sonado alarmas
antiaéreas ni se registraron disparos de
cohetes por parte de las milicias de
hamás hacia israel ni ataques del
ejército israelí sobre gaza la tregua
pone fin a 11 días de escalada bélica
que han dejado 243 palestinos muertos en
casa y otras 12 personas en israel
palestinos de la franja a cisjordania y
jerusalén este
celebraron la medida en las calles
calificándolo como una derrota del
gobierno de israelí pero por su parte el
ejecutivo israelí también se adjudicó el
éxito al considerar que la campaña
militar alcanzó grandes logros sin
precedentes contra objetivos militares
de las milicias de los grupos islamistas
hamas y la jihad islámica a pesar de la
tranquilidad de las posibilidades las
miradas se centran hoy sobre los restos
de los musulmanes en la explanada en las
mezquitas como todos
estamos entonces un vistazo a cómo
comenzó y se desarrolló el más reciente
conflicto palestino-israelí los ataques
más violentos de la última escalada
bélica sobre el situado sitiado en clave
de la franja de gaza informa marina
sardina
el barrio de sheikh jarrah en jerusalén
este fue el punto de partida del
conflicto el detonante fueron las
tensiones ante el posible desalojo al
que se enfrentaban docenas de familias
palestinas una organización de colonos
judíos reclaman las tierras como propias
el máximo tribunal israelí tenía
previsto anunciar su decisión el 10 de
mayo pero pospuso su fallo añadiendo más
tensión que derivó en fuertes
enfrentamientos en medio de los restos
del ramadán en la mezquita de al-aqsa la
policía israelí se enfrentó a la
multitud con gases lacrimógenos y balas
de goma las fuerzas israelíes
irrumpieron en la explanada de las
mezquitas por la fuerza hiriendo a
cientos de palestinos unos incidentes
que suscitaron la condena de la
comunidad musulmana entonces el
movimiento islamista hamás comenzó a
lanzar cohetes desde gaza en represalia
por lo que consideró crímenes y
agresiones de israel hacia los árabes de
jerusalén la respuesta israelí no se
hizo esperar bajo la llamada 'operación
guardián de los muros lanzó decenas de
ataques aéreos sobre gaza mientras hamas
e israel intercambiaban bombardeos
l'aire la violencia se extendieron a las
calles de las ciudades mixtas
y la comunidad internacional presionó
para poner fin a las hostilidades con el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
llevando a cabo reuniones de emergencia
pero cuyas resoluciones serán bloqueadas
por eeuu el presidente joe biden reiteró
su pedido a israel para desescalar el
conflicto que este viernes finalizó con
un cese al fuego bilateral acordado con
la mediación de egipto en 11 días jamás
disparó más de 4000 cohetes contra
israel la mayoría interceptados por el
sistema de defensa cúpula de hierro los
proyectiles que atravesaron mataron a 12
personas en gaza- la destrucción y la
violencia fue mucho mayor
los bombardeos derribaron edificios
escuelas hospitales matando a más de 230
personas entre ellas 65 niños provocando
el desplazamiento interno de más de
70.000 palestinos
y es que la comunidad internacional
celebra el alto el fuego en gaza y pide
soluciones duraderas
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
elogió el cese de hostilidades afirmando
que su país ayudaría a gaza con ayuda
humanitaria y que repondría el sistema
de defensa antimisiles cúpula de hierro
de israel que ayuda a repeler los
cohetes de hamas alemania advirtió que
se deben abordar las causas profundas
del conflicto y la unión europea subrayó
la importancia de una solución política
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres pidió a los líderes de las
partes que comiencen un serio diálogo
sobre la raíz de este conflicto
previamente hablamos desde tel aviv con
nuestra corresponsal maya simonovic con
ella conversamos sobre los ganadores y
los perdedores de estos días en este
conflicto veamos lo que nos dijo
es muy difícil determinar que haya un
ganador con tantos muertos
particularmente en gaza'
sin embargo es ya histórico que tanto
israel como hamás cada vez que han
tenido un conflicto de estos ya van
cuatro siempre declaran la victoria es
una cuestión de propaganda lo que se
critica al gobierno de netanyahu con
respecto al no logró en gaza es que no
ha logrado disuadir a hamás ni siquiera
a terminar con todas sus lanzaderas de
cohetes y van a seguir probablemente en
una siguiente desafortunada futura ronda
tirando proyectiles a donde consigan
tanto a las comunidades colindantes con
gaza incluso a tel aviv donde hemos
recibido también bastantes misiles por
su parte en gaza seguramente la lectura
de una victoria tiene que ver con que
israel ha accedido a un alto el fuego
incondicional estas son las
interpretaciones
y también hablamos sobre el papel
mediador del vecino egipto veamos
egipto es muy importante en este
conflicto en este conflicto y en los
cuatro anteriores que han tenido israel
y hamás desde gaza de hecho egipto
empezó a perfilarse como un factor de
conversación clave entre los islamistas
de hamas y el gobierno israelí desde que
israel se retiró de gaza en 2005 y
después cuando hamás se ocupó el poder
en 2007 y empezaron los conflictos
abiertos
egipto siempre ha jugado un papel clave
de mediación y en esta ocasión también
comenzó a gestionar una posible un
posible alto el fuego una tregua en el
primer día en el que se empezaron a
lanzar cohetes y lo ha conseguido ha
sido rechazado en varias ocasiones por
ambas partes y sin embargo fue recibido
ayer y han llegado un marco de acuerdo
que ambos podían aceptar que es una
tregua sin condiciones
cambiamos ahora información en españa' a
pesar de la cierta tranquilidad que se
vive en la ciudad de ceuta fronteriza
con marruecos después de que ocho mil
migrantes intentarán ingresar de los
cuales seis mil ya han sido devueltos a
su país cientos de africanos intentaron
entrar esta vez esta madrugada a la
ciudad española de melilla también desde
marruecos una treintena de ellos si
consiguió cruzar la frontera a pesar del
despliegue del ejército hasta el momento
no se sabe a dónde fueron trasladados
los que llegaron hasta este enclave
mientras que en ceuta 800 menores siguen
acogidos en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad
[Música]
y es que este reciente aumento de las
llegadas de inmigrantes a españa se
produce después de una disputa entre ese
país y marruecos por el sahara
occidental que fue una antigua colonia
española y desde 1975 ha sido reclamada
tanto por marruecos como por el frente
polisario demos a dar un vistazo a como
los territorios en disputa contribuyen a
las tensiones entre madrid y rabat
el sahara occidental- estuvo bajo la
soberanía española desde la década de
1880 hasta mediados de 1970 después de
la retirada de españa marruecos se anexó
alrededor de dos tercios del territorio
pero los marroquíes se enfrentaron con
la feroz resistencia de un grupo armado
que pidió la independencia de la región
en 1976 el frente polisario declaró la
creación de la república árabe saharaui
democrática el conflicto que duró
décadas volvió a estallar en 2020
después de que se estancará las
negociaciones de la onu mientras que el
frente polisario acusa a españa de
eludir sus responsabilidades como
antigua potencia colonial y de no ayudar
activamente a la o no a organizar un
referendo sobre el autodeterminación
marruecos por otro lado no dude en
reaccionar si alguien intenta socavar su
reclamo sobre la tierra en disputa el
mes pasado el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores en rabat advirtió que habría
consecuencias después de que madrid
dejara que el líder del frente polisario
ibrahim ghali recibiera tratamiento
hospitalario en españa el año pasado
cuando alemania criticó a eeuu
por respaldar a rabat marruecos retiro
al embajador alemán de su país y cortó
lazos con las instituciones culturales
de la nación europea españa está
interesada en mantener relaciones
positivas con su vecino del sur debido
al potencial económico y la posición
estratégica del país norteafricano los
dos también comparten fronteras
terrestres los únicos cruces de este
tipo entre la unión europea y un país
africano son ceuta y melilla vestigios
de la colonización española y portuguesa
del siglo 15 son dos enclaves rodeados
por marruecos por un lado y el mar
mediterráneo por el otro rabat ha
exigido durante mucho tiempo el control
de las dos ciudades pero sus esfuerzos
han sido inútiles
y los estados miembros de la unión
europea llegaron a un acuerdo para
empezar